good morning everybody welcome to the
second day of our technology conference
and I'm going to talk about the
mathematica compiler the Wolfram
language compiler and efforts that we've
had first at a compilation so I'm going
to review lots of you will know lots
about the compiler but maybe I ask a
question first of all how many people
here use the mathematic of the existing
compile function right good so that's
that's quite a good presumably for speed
that's your main reason okay sounds good
so I'm just going to a quick review of
the rhythm compiler there might be some
people here who are not familiar with it
just make sure everybody knows where
we're coming from and what's existing
now I'm giving then switch on to talking
about some new development efforts that
we've been working on and I'm going to
try and not be too technical but it will
be a little bit technical just to give
you a warning so right so where is the
compiler generally a compiler can be
further something to translate computer
source code from run programming
language into another but very typically
you are going to translate from a
high-level language into a low-level
language for reasons you know for
example for execution so you can
translate your high-level language like
C++ into a low-level language the sort
of machine code that runs on the Intel
processor and you can get faster
execution the low-level language might
be simpler able to execute faster the
translation process itself very often
optimizes things removes onions code etc
they often income
Tyler's not know always it invokes a
type system and that gives you some part
of there's a type system that's part of
the compilation and that gives you some
sort of guarantee one of the features of
type system is it tells you that the
program can always move forwards it
won't it won't get stuck that there'll
always be a root a function to move
forwards compression you can also work
with other technologies multi-core
things are the compilers GPS other
languages sometimes you can use parts of
the concept of compilation is your
understanding the code that's being
compiled and that can give you
information other information warnings
you know this variables not being used
this you know the output of this
complicated thing is not it's not being
used this you know and and such like
this variables not being initialized
might lead to an error and it's a
compiler that you need to understand the
language to get morning's like that and
another type of thing this is really
like a translation thing is refactoring
so to rewrite your code in some way to
do that correctly you have to understand
what it is and that's what a compiler
can do so the real firm language
compiler just give a quick it's quick
demo so it's a bit like so we have
lambda functions in Mathematica so we
also have rated that we have compile so
you just replace function with compile
that's the formal argument and execute
it and you get the get the same same
answer but it's taking two different
routes to get there it's actually the
compiled function is using so here's the
compile function it's using you can see
the internals and it's like a bunch of
integer is a bytecode more useful way of
looking at it is this sort of compiled
print so here is the function we had
sort of x squared + sine of x squared
and then when we execute it these are
the actual instructions here that are
being executed so one thing you might
notice is that it's only even though x
squared appeared twice it's actually
combine those so it's only squaring the
input variable once so that's like an
optimization kind of a nice nice
optimization here's another more
complicated one this has this is a sort
of table command and this has been
turned into a you have to read all these
instructions but it's basically added a
loop into the into the bytecode now so
are compiled functions there like an
expression and so we can write
Mathematica programs to work with it so
one of the things we did was to add some
code translation and this is taking the
compiled function and it's generating C
code from the compile function this is C
code but you can actually execute and so
we went one stage further which was in
compile we added this compilation target
goes to C and so you get a compile
function and it executes but this time
the compiled function instead of using
the bytecode virtual machine that's
built into the system it's actually
dynamically generated a dynamic library
and it's calling into that so that's
making use of the Wolfram language tools
for working with C compilers and
labelling and another feature of compile
is if you can see this is we have
various we can make the compile function
B list of all and we can set it set the
paralyzation true and this is a very
fine-grained form of paralyzation of
multi-core support
in the kernel and so it's able to if
there are multiple cores it executes
those in in parallel so just a quick
some quick explanations so the normal
usage is we have the mathematical import
go into the compiler and it creates a
compiled function which has virtual
machine instructions when reset
comparation target goes to see it takes
different route it goes to the compiler
that generates C code that goes into a
dynamic library and the dynamic library
is loaded and that's that's how it
executes for the parallel execution so
it's a list of all compiled function so
the compile function is applied to each
argument in the list in sequence so
that's like the stability in general in
Mathematica but since the compiled
function has the more tightly controlled
semantics we were able to execute this
in in parallel so here's the parallel
execution so this will be with two cores
so you would take you know you take two
two arguments from your list give them
in each each thread you'd execute those
and suchlike and of course this you know
this generalizes out if you had six
cores or 16 cores you can get a parallel
acceleration from from the compiled code
so this is something that's not
available in the normal Mathematica
interpreter evaluator too much state
that it has too much shared state would
make it not not work for compiled for
parallel execution right just shut you
on here quick history initial version
introduced in Mathematica to 1991
version 3 we added tensors so this is
like full ranked so this is like a
matrix or
to each each length has that each
dimension has to have the same length
and this was very useful very powerful
it made made the compiler much more
useful to be able to compile things like
this partly because with this we were
able to compile a load of the language
so and in fact we will automatically
invoke for things like table and
suchlike we automatically invoke compile
version 4 we added this pact or a notion
which was taking the tensor concept and
letting these tenses sort of leak out of
compile into the rest of the system and
that's what packed arrays were and then
the another advance was in the
cogeneration and power execution and
that was added in version 8 quick now
let's look at some challenges and
suchlike so so the Wolfram language is a
very dynamic language so so you'll
compiler you want you know he's hopeful
to have some sort of type system but the
mathematica doesn't have doesn't have
you know it's like one time typing so
you don't really know the type of
something until the code is executing
compiled let's around this by adding the
types on the input to the to the
function and then it infers does a type
inferencing system to sort of deduce the
types in the code another type of issue
for the Wolfram language is its symbolic
nature now for computational it's not
necessarily a problem but if you have
things that bind values later and that's
actually sort of a feature of infinite
evaluation that that is a problem
because it means you don't at
compilation time you don't necessarily
know what your code is of course
compilers have ways around you know of
dealing with things like that and then
there's other challenges specific
features by cup values and sequence and
things like that so those are some of
the challenges
and then here are some of the
limitations and I know about some of
these limitations because some of you
folk here I've told me how do I do this
how do I do that so these are some of
them limitations one of these do do
relate to the type system so it only
works for simple types bullion's integer
real complex and tenses of the numeric
types so doesn't support like strings or
association or big numbers or 16 bit
unsigned integers or you know etc
doesn't support those but that would be
useful you can't define types if I
wanted to introduce you know like some
structural record you can't you can't do
that type system doesn't have any know
types so so I'll talk about those a bit
more later doesn't support function
types so you can't it supports function
in compiled code but it purely in lines
the function so it can't pass a function
around and even more usefully is that
function that's passed around it doesn't
keep you know doesn't keep its binding
two variables and that's a very powerful
concept that makes you think all the
closure it's not very good for one
compiled function calling another and in
particular it's not very good for
recursive calls so it's like old fortran
77 which didn't support recursion so
don't integrate with the pattern matcher
it's hard to extend either by you or by
us and it doesn't really use the latest
knowledge of compilers or technology so
in order to work on this we have been
for a long time I have been thinking
that it would be nice to I'm just going
to
that it would be there lot of potential
compilers a very useful piece feature
lot of people get good good utility out
of it but we're missing something and
the old compile system come to end of
its life it's hard to sort of build on
top of what we need is a new development
project to work on a new you know
second-generation Wolfram language
compiler and I'm giving you this is a
work in progress so this is a
development project that's been going on
for about bit about a year I've we've
had various efforts before that but this
is a really serious effort one of the
things that's actually helped in this is
the new feature Association that's that
was added in version 10 and that allows
this helps us to write develop new
programming paradigms that are that are
useful for this another feature of the
gnu compiler is that it's very much
built on top of principles of
compilation technology and techniques so
it uses you know modern compiler
knowledge and techniques and it's very
compatible with modern compiler
technologies in particular this this
thing called llvm and i'll i'll be
talking about that so the task what's
the task i'm going to go through the
steps in in the compile so we're
translating Wolfram language into a form
that can be executed more quickly so
we're going to start with a
tree-structured mathematical expression
which will be a mathematica program and
we're going to convert that into a
linear sequence of instructions so how
are we going to do that so the first
thing we have to do is we need to have a
way of representing the syntax tree of
the mathematical expression but we have
to do this in a way
that it doesn't sort of evaluate from
under underneath you and this is
something there's all sorts of tricks
and things that people around here of
have introduced the way that we went to
do solve this was to have a radically
different like a whole new data
structure built out of associations that
represented the expression and that
makes it completely easy to work on the
to work on these expressions so we call
them mm experts and they support you
know things like much of the API the
programming interface for for
expressions so I can get like the first
part so the first part is is this I can
go back into a regular expression if if
I want to so another thing that we did
was that there are nice concepts in in
the Wolfram language like pattern
matching so so what we did was we wrote
a pattern matcher that operated that
supported mathematical programming
pattern constructs on these M experts so
this is a match Q function so it's
matching against this and it's using
this as the pattern and you match that
and we get the arcs are true so that's
that's good and we have another this is
like a replace all so this is everything
that matches this pattern it's it's
going to replace that so let's do a bit
more if I come and put here's another so
it's very much like the mathematica
packing mature but it's but it's a
different implementation and this came
out of something that I implemented
quite a while ago for workbench which
also has a pattern matcher and that's
able to do refactoring and searching in
your Wolfram source code using
Mathematica patent language which is
kind of a cool thing this is you using a
pattern matcher which you know
manipulate
syntrax trees and I'll show you why
that's useful in in a minute well I less
than a minute I'll show you you thought
now because the reason that we want to
do that is we want also to have a macro
system so the old compiler has has a
macro system that some of you I know
that like Oliver for example has delved
into this it grew up organically it's a
bit opaque it's a bit hard to work with
and this is a much more fundamental
thing and the idea of the macro system
in compiler is you you rewrite some of
your code so you don't need you see it's
because we're lazy and we want to go and
read Wikipedia or you know do something
different with our lives or look at you
know so we don't want to write
translations into our compilation code
for every function all we do is we write
it for a subset and then we translate
other things into that subset so here's
for example an and and i'm going to
write i'm going to expand the macro and
so we've turned the and into a another
expression and so this other expression
is the thing that will combine that will
that will compile so we don't need to
write compilation for and we just need
to you know make make make it work on
this sort of branching here's another
one so this is like this inequality
thing so this actually goes through two
steps so first of all it turns into an
end of these two equality inequality
expressions and then the and has has
sort of a you know expanded so this is
how we implemented the system there's
still the macro system for people who
are aficionados in this it's it's um you
know it still has a little bit more work
it might need to introduce local
variables prevent side effects things
like that it might also if it introduces
local variables it needs to do that in a
way that doesn't conflict with the
system that's around that but but there
are these are well understood problem
is that you know they're not specific to
Mathematica Wolfram language right
that's the macro system now what we want
to do is we want to take the input so
here I'm giving the input is being a
compile expression but I'm going to work
with it in this new system and this runs
along here and it's generated this thing
called a program module and the program
module contains a list of all of the
individual functions the reason for this
is that inside this compiled function we
might have other other functions inside
of this and the way to compile that is
you left all the nested functions up to
the top and then you have a way of
reaching them but this this one here
only has one as a function module and
then inside of it it's got some
instruction it's got a list of these
those starts to get a bit of a pic I'll
talk about what these are in a minute
but here's a another way of looking at
it so here's the the code for this very
simple function 2x plus 1 so we're
loading the argument we're multiplying
the constant this is the constant two
and we're multiplying it by the input
variable the variable there then we're
going to do an addition and then we are
going to return the result now this this
code has a couple of properties and I'll
show you one more property that it has
so here I've got a branch and I'm
showing this now in a different printing
form now what this branching is done is
it's it split the programmed sections
into blocks these are things called
basic blocks and the property of the
basic block is you never leave or enter
in the middle you enter at the top and
you exit out at the bottom that's that's
how it works so this there are there are
these
has four basic blocks so it starts up
here and then there's it either goes to
this one or it goes to this one and then
they end up at this sort of ending
ending result now there's another
property that this code this is probably
getting too technical but each each of
these variables only ever gets assigned
to once so you only assigned two
variables once and that's very useful
and the reason why you want to do that
is it makes any transformations or
optimizations or whatever is very simple
to do because you don't have to if if a
variable hood was assigned to in many
places and you wanted to remove that
variable you'd have to keep track of it
it would be much harder each one only
has one one usage so here's a slightly
more complicated input function and here
we go and so this is this is a while so
we have to support a few of these
because many things will use the macro
system to turn them into ifs and wiles
and things like that so that that that
makes it simpler so we've also added a
bunch of optimizations to the system so
here's the same thing but I'm setting
the optimization level 20 and there's
you know there's many more instructions
you see down here there's kind of like a
a copy instruction you see we're copying
14 to 15 and then we're returning it but
in fact you could just return you know
return something and a final step is
we're going to convert everything into
out of this single assignment form into
a sort of register allocation thing and
that's where we we might actually reuse
the same the same register and this uses
a standard algorithm for allocating
registers right so that's the I've shown
there starting with an input expression
and then converting it into the sort of
intermediate
now before we actually go into the sort
of outside you know to take it further
to start executing it we need to have a
type system so this is some view into
the type system that I've that I'll give
you now that we've been developing now
type systems themselves are very
interesting and there's you know it's
probably more people here that know
about mathematics and logic than
computer science type systems but
actually they're the same thing and
there's a correspondence between logic
and type systems that's actually very
interesting and I think in general any
parts of computer technology that touch
pure maths suppose you know that have
this correspondence I think that's for
not enormously interesting so and the
time system itself is like a programming
language but it's a higher level
programming language where you do
reasoning about the code that you have
so the time system we have it has
specification of basic types like the
old type system but it has more of them
and you could introduce new ones it has
a type inferencing system but a more you
know a more modern more robust type
inferencing thing has tight extension so
you can add compound types function
types it has which is very useful it has
a notion of generic types so in terms of
logic I think that's going up to first
order logic where you have quantifiers
there's this correspondence that's this
that's there and so here's just some
quick quick idea so this is like an
integer and here is a compound type so
this is the thing that we how we specify
packed arrays you don't have to type
this if this is all the internal
mechanism so this is a we're applying
this type vector and we're applying it
to the argument integer so this is a
type this is a patter a of right one of
integer
and of course you can nest these things
so if we added applied another type
vector to that we'd have a matrix around
2 PAC to row so this is this is how the
type system would reference them this is
the name that we give to a function type
so this is the type of a function that
takes a real argument and returns an
integer so very useful to have functions
in in the type system here's a type
another type of atomic type so this is a
32-bit integer very nice be able to
specify that in in a formal way and one
important note none of these these names
of course this 32-bit integer that's
just the name so there's nothing in it
that says it's holding 32 bits it's just
a name that gets sort of propagated
through the system but but none of these
are hard-coded and it's it's it's it is
quite general first is have a little
look at the influencing system so here
I'm going to I've made a function that
takes an integer returns a real and now
what i've done is i've made a function
that takes an integer but now the output
is an unknown so I I don't know what the
output is so you do this in type
inferencing so now i'm going to unify
that's the name that you give to to this
these these two functions and now when I
look at the output variable it's
actually it tells me that the output
variable is real so this is telling me
that you know if I call this function
with a integer the output will be a real
so that's that's pretty useful here's
here's another thing so this is
something that's I'm invoking a
quantifier so this is I have a function
here and this is a function and it takes
a generic type variable and it returns
that same variable this is the type it
doesn't mean so this would be a function
that took an integer and returns another
integer and or a function that took a
real and return to real or a list in a
list so this might be an identity
function but it isn't it's not saying
it's returning the same thing it's just
returning a thing of the same type so
now i'm going to do do a type inference
on this so I unify so I'm going to
convert combine it with a function that
takes an integer but I don't know what
the output is so I combine this and if i
look at the output variable it's an
integer so that's that's that's that's
that's pretty useful so this is a
generic generic function so that's
that's pretty useful in the old compiler
we had to write special case code for
things like this so now we have a
language that deals with these things
sort of you know it's much more
expressive so that's that's definitely
definitely better and of course you can
go up you know and don't you can go
there's power levels of logic that you
can go to if you need to generic
functions right after we've reached the
intermediate code we start applying
optimization passes and this is a dual
made this picture here this is at the
current time these the optimization
passes that we don't look that we're
applying so for example here's a thing
to all you'd have to go look at this to
the first one is we're looking at doing
something with function slots and then
this is a pass this def pass is
something that tells whether something
is defined this is something that tells
whether it's used this this pass here
finds the range over which variables are
in use that's that's needed for example
for the register allocator and various
things you know this thing here avoids
you know you know moving
Constance around it can just put the
constant in its use place and then
eliminate variables so there's like a
bunch of these you know you can merge
blocks and remove jumps and things like
that working with this sort of static
assignment and basic block structure
makes these passes easier to work with
so another thing that's kind of neat
about working with this that's being is
course you know we're developing
compiler but it's developed in
Mathematica so we can use Mathematica
for doing the I'm not all right I've
lost I've lost my flow graph there um
but we can use some sort of
visualizations and things and so here's
this is a function here this is how you
might write in Mathematica with fixed
point how you might write a fractal to
sort of computer Julia set so this is
the various instructions that we might
go down into right now this this
intermediate code that we have is fine
for transforming and suchlike but really
we want to execute it and so we need a
back end you know we need to translate
this into some sort of byte code for an
actual machine so one thing that we've
done is we've supported with the
implementation we have we built it to
support the existing Mathematica virtual
machine so so we have this to compiled
function it's taking compile and it's
returning a compiled function which
executes in the normal way except and
it's nice you know sort of optimized
code except this one here was was done
with our new system not not not with the
old system and this has been pretty
useful for sort of experimenting and
innovating with with with with with
functions now
one of the goals that I gave for the
system was to work with you know more
you know more more more types so not
just integers and rails and so one of
things that we did was we added support
for strings so here's a compiled
function and now what I'm saying is the
argument is a is a string and then I'm
going to apply the string joint function
and so if i call you know call this i
get you know get get the and i could
compose this you know with other other
functions and if we look at the
instruction code here's the here's
here's the bytecode so it's pretty
simple the input is is a string and
that's holding held in this sort of 0 0
and then that calls the string joint
function and that returns the you know
it returns the output I think adding
strings to compile it's like super
useful actually but we'd also like to go
further and support Association strings
and and your own types as well but but
to have that in a in an efficient way so
sure
Yeah right right right so that's that's
something that that we haven't
implemented yet so for reasons of trying
to finish something and deliver
something where we're looking to target
the existing compile framework which is
for anonymous function similar to lambda
functions that's that but there's
absolutely no reason why not and and you
know I like I can talk more about that
later but that's absolutely one of the
goals is to integrate and actually when
you're compiling things you actually
know if you can see all the patterns you
have to match against probably maybe you
can statically select which which
function to use you know you don't have
to go and apply an expensive pattern
matching you know implementation so
absolutely that's that's a feature it's
just I don't have an example you know we
have worked on that because we're
focusing on finishing something you know
I'm calling an internal function string
join and I'm saying it takes two
arguments string string and it returns a
string that's just the name that's it
that's like I'm making an external call
to a built-in function but I compound
expression will have a type so the
mangling would have the name of that be
the name of that type
well their name angling it has to be
that well it's a string so it has to be
valid you know see or something name so
but and we maybe we'll need some
aliasing thing to give to give the types
names or something so yeah right right I
mean these things like it quite long
Yeah Yeah right I just put this into
right now this is similar but a little
bit different so this is I'm taking
compile and what I'm doing now is I'm
saying everything that the compile is
working for is going to be an expert an
expression might not mean everything to
everybody here but for some people it
will so this is a compiled function and
I can call it you know right i'm just
adding to adds its arguments but but
this compile function it's it's taking
expressions not not integers or reals or
something so that means it can work but
for any expression so here's here's
here's a big none the same same function
or hears you know some some sort of
symbolic thing let's see there's the
code so this is we've got sort of e two
arguments easy row e 1 and we're going
to add them together and here's a
slightly bigger example not super big
butt so I'm going to compile this and
some optimization of the optimization is
needed so I can call this compiled
function again here's the code we have
and so it's what do we have here we're
calling the less on the expression here
we're casting the
spur to a boolean to implement the
branch this isn't a loop so and then
then we're doing some addition you know
what are we doing we're adding one of
the yeah this is the counter and going
down for loop and then we're and this
actually this simple example just to
show you this is running so this is how
you'd write the same function without
the compiler and actually quite quite
nicely it runs you get kind of a nice
speed up now I haven't shown a lot of
speed examples you know speed up but but
I think this is this is really quite
interesting and this is maybe the most
profound thing in the mathematical
language for sort of thirst you know
however long it is you know yours
because this is executing expression
code without using the expression
interpreter the AST interpreter that we
normally use but using a you know a you
know an alternative system that's that's
that's faster and you can say the ton of
work with with this sort of thing and
this sort of starts your question a
minute but this this lends itself very
well to small little functions so
compiling all the mathematica is quite
you know is quite quite quite quite
challenging but you know I might have
something you know list you know this
might have something like this so I
might want to sort something give a
special sort function now very often
when I write code I sometimes avoid
writing these sorts of things because I
know that the applying the custom
function just invoking this custom sort
function is going to be expensive and
it'll be more expensive from the
built-in things which were written in C
but if we could compile these things and
execute them in some efficient way it
would be as though they were written in
city and it would make these things
faster that's in
obviously maybe we could even run the
sort function in the in compile as well
but just being able to invoke small
functions in an alternative way and get
a speed enhancement I think is very
powerful and I think that will have a
good impact on the utility of of the
system so I think that's quite exciting
there are values it won't work won't
work that doesn't fall in floor it'll
just go back it can always go back to
the old system and so it'll absolutely
if you throw in sequence up values it'll
use the old system and it'll work
correctly in the same way that it always
did with the entrance to the compile
would detect that up values are attached
to things and we have expensive
machinery in the system to detect these
things so if you have those it'll you'll
get the right answer you won't get any
benefits so right but actually when you
start to use these things it's not so up
values become less useful as well
actually so you can actually reach your
world where up values are not useful you
know the reason why you you search you
reach for them no longer exists because
there's it's fast enough without them
you see right Seth you had a question
Yeah Yeah right and I'm keeping it as a
symbolic thing yes and executing it and
I think that's very powerful right now
in general things that's you know is
Jason came up with something and I'm
sure you know you could just keep a you
know long stream of these things ya
ain't going to work for these
complicated things but when you go and
look at the you know five hundred
thousand lines of mathematical code that
are in the system you know many of you
know 499 you know five hundred thousand
lines of code I would guess four hundred
ninety nine thousand nine hun- of those
lines of code you know that they don't
use features they're going to stop stop
confirmation and probably that's that's
the same case for you know for many of
use even then it's not impossible to
imagine some sort of you know sort of
jit system where you start to detect
that you know I mean so it's not
impossible that's how you know like
JavaScript compilers work you know is
the JavaScript doesn't know what what it
has so it's runs the code collect
statistics and it says oh yes this
function has been called a hundred times
with a you know an object that's you
know has an integer and a string I'll go
and get create a specialized version
that's optimized for this so that that
that that you know those sorts of things
are possible so but not not not not
immediately people that write compile
code as well now don't don't don't
suffer from you know the lack of that
now keep keep an eye on I want to talk
now about this sort of very back end the
execution of the of the code maybe not
the execution of the code but so I want
y'all got this thing called llvm so this
is a compiler infrastructure that
provides large collections of compilers
and compiler tools that
work with all sorts of different input
languages and output targets and output
languages as well and the really key key
point about llvm is it carefully written
something that might be familiar to
Mathematica it's it's it's very
carefully designed to be reusable and
very carefully designed to be extensible
so it has a big contrast in some ways
it's a little similar to GCC but it's
nicely designed so I started to think of
it if we built a compiler if we built
it's like if we were going to build GCC
it's how we would build it or I would
hope we would and that's that's that's a
very key point about llvm is that it's
nicely designed and it has these nice
api's and so you can use it and extend
it right at the middle it has this
well-defined intermediate representation
so llvm how many people here use a Mac
good so on the Mac for quite a long time
llvm has been part of the standard tools
that you use for C code generation how
many people here use see on the Mac yeah
right so some of you you see on the Mac
maybe some of you are stubborn and
you've installed GCC but very likely
you're using the clan compiler tool
chain and clang is part of the llvm set
of tools and I think now you know maybe
even a few years ago clan words you know
it wasn't quite as fast as GCC I don't
think that said you you know that's
that's not truly longer it's it's it's
really nice and fast so so Apple have a
big investment in llvm but it's it's
every big company software technology
company are buying into llvm and
adapting some of it so like for example
Microsoft have this sort of there's the
answer i'm not an expert on mono and the
common run time but i think they're
making some new version of mono
it's based around llvm and there's a ton
of tools that work with llvm but can you
do debugging on the mac you're not using
gdb you're using lld be you know so that
means if you're working with the
intermediate representation you've got a
debugger for it immediately you don't
need to write debugger you just just use
lld be so and there's just a ton of
tools for working with llvm translating
it you know sir etc and it's very so why
is it relevant for us so it's it's very
suitable for integrating with our
compiler project and and the compile
project that I'm describing has been
carefully designed not totally
accidentally to be very compatible with
llvm so many of the concepts that I've
been talking about these basic blocks
and static those are passes and things
like that those are ideas those are sort
of you know concepts in llvm so here's
just a little snippet of the really you
don't have to look at it in too much
detail and so that's what I put code
like this up half people walk out but
apologies so this is the intermediate
representation of this is the
intermediate language that llvm users so
here's a this is I can add to this is
kind of the meat of it and add to
function so we're basically it's a
function that returns a integer 64 it
takes two arguments it's going to add
them and it's going to return them
there's all sorts of other metadata and
stuff like that but that's some you know
things like this no unwind I think that
means it doesn't throw any exceptions
things like that and in this
intermediate code there's a ton of
functionality you can have this support
if you want to add a garbage collector
to this which we will need to support
these string objects and things like
that it's it's all been thought of and
there's a mature set of things for this
here
I are with a branch so this is you know
this is just a simple thing so it's a
function i shouldn't've call the add to
sorry take intermediate representation
this is the intermediate code but you
see it has the same concept of these
basic blocks so so what we have is very
compatible with this llvm intermediate
representation so so you have this lli
our vm well you know what to do within
us so what well you can take it you can
run optimizations and the llvm tools
come with a ton of optimizations that a
suitable or transform things or you know
you know clever you know there's the
world is stuffed full of computer
science departments who study these
things and produce you know code that's
compatible with it and so we can work
with it vert it into other languages so
those things like well what one thing
that's actually quite useful for us is
there are tools to take ir and convert
it back into see that helps to sort of
study it or we can incorporate it into
other tools such like that we have there
are projects there's a thing to generate
cuda code GPU code there's this M
scriptum thing that generates JavaScript
code so once you're going into this I
are you've got a lot of options open to
you but one nice thing you want to do is
you want to execute it and there's this
thing called llvm jit and this takes the
this intermediate code and it generates
a function pointer that you can execute
and call and that's pretty nice because
it means you don't have to go through a
linker you see so you're saving a ton of
work because the c compiler generates
like an object file or a library or
shared or static library then it invokes
another program that assembles all these
things and but it just totally cuts that
out you don't need any anything like
that but it's very you know it's as
optimized as though it went through the
linker which which is pretty nice so
in order to this is like super new stuff
and it does we don't quite have
everything I wanted to show but even
this is very nice so we're starting to
work with a link to llvm tools and so
this is taking the the add to
intermediate representation that I had
before and I'm passing it to a function
that invokes llvm tools and it returns
this llvm function and i can add two
numbers together using oops didn't like
that and suchlike now this I are I
actually generated by running clang
obviously we want to generate the ir
ourselves just not quite working yet but
here's like an explanation that's really
kind of key what I'm showing here is
this is virtually identical to putting
compilation target goes to see how many
people here use compilation target goes
to see right so you will never have to
do that again it will just happen
automatically for you which is kind of
nice but you won't have compilation
target goes to see has some negatives
that you have to invoke this big
complicated thing called a compiler and
sometimes that can be kind of slow think
Rob had robbed nap found something once
and it took like three hours to for
visual studio he gets a monstrous fine i
tell you know the sort of monstrous
thing that Robert big they even with you
know the nice expression optimizer it
took three hours for visual studio to
compile it so got once it have been
compiled it ran very fast but that's
this this this is kind of a you know an
alternative and you'll have you know
solutions to sort of you know it's a
more streamlined way of doing it so it's
similar to compilation Tyler goes to see
but it's much much simpler and much
easier to control them right so I think
I'm just coming to the end and I'm going
to sort of wrap up I mean there's tons
more things that that I could be talking
about
this is definitely a you know working
progress this isn't finished but I think
we're starting to see all the bits that
we need to put together so just
summarize I i looked at the existing
compiler and its features and benefits
and some of its weaknesses and then I
looked at some of the torch the path the
root of the new Wolfram compiler and the
sort of path that it took them going
from mathematical code to things that
would could be executed how this is
destined to be a replacement for the
existing compile functionality a
second-generation compiler it'll have
support for you know new types and
expose and then I looked at how we are
going to integrate you know output into
and integrate with the llvm technology
and I think this will be a really
exciting new direction to take the
Wolfram language in and we'll get some
nice benefits from this anyway so I'll
wrap up thank you very much